new titles coming to Xbox game pass in
February include atomic heart Madden 23
and Mount And Blade to Banner Lord let's
start with the end of the month atomic
heart is a new game coming to the
service on February 21st looking like a
Bioshock if it was set in Russia atomic
heart takes place in a robot Utopia gone
wrong as Humanity's automatons have
decided to start a deadly robot Uprising
the perfect game to drop on Valentine's
Day Mount And Blade 2 battlelord is set
in the Dark Ages combined strategy and
action RPG gameplay and tasks you with
conquering a deadly land so that your
kingdom can rise Madden 23 will be the
game coming soonest to the subscription
service on February 9th don't think I
need to explain what that one is about
it's Madden it's the latest one I've
said a full list of all the new Game
Pass editions can be found at
gamespot.com a game that will eventually
come to Xbox game pass via a play but
unfortunately not at launch is Jedi
Survivor recently delayed from March
17th to April 28th the marketing cycle
for this game is about to jump to light
speed and new gameplay details are
coming in faster than an X-Wing the
game's director Stig as Museum explains
that the new lightsaber type the cross
guard Hilt variant popularized by Darth
wannabe kylo Ren will make for a heavier
fighting style than the other options
another new addition is the Blaster
stance which allows for protagonist
calcast to wield both a blaster and a
lightsaber at once a traditionally
Blasphemous move that would make Obi-Wan
blush as mucin explained that this new
Option allows for ranged combat which
wasn't really present in the first game
other than if the player would fling
their lightsaber however the ranged
combat plays it probably won't feel like
Call of Duty which just unveiled the
second season of its latest release
Modern Warfare 2. the second season sees
the in introduction of resurgence modes
to Warzone 2.0 ranked play to the
regular multiplayer as well as new maps
and returning modes Resurgence mode will
take place on a new Warzone map called
ashika Island this is a much smaller map
than the main almazra one and the mode
will allow for multiple times player
respawns as long as one of their
teammates is left standing ashika Island
will also be available in the game's
extraction mode DMZ for the full list of
new additions and changes to Modern
Warfare 2 Warzone 2.0 and DMZ heads to
gamespot.com season 2 will bring free
content to those that already own the
game but if you want to play The Legend
of Zelda tears of the Kingdom you're
going to need to Fork over some money
and now it might be more than you were
prepared to spend yesterday evening the
Nintendo switch eShop showed a 70 price
for the highly anticipated sequel the
price has since been removed from the
eShop but that doesn't necessarily mean
it was an error not long after the 70
price point circulated on social media
every major retailer stopped taking
pre-orders for tears of the Kingdom the
game had been available to pre-order for
sixty dollars since last summer so
retailers may have wanted to stop the
flood of orders at the lower price point
ahead of a potential announcement during
today's Nintendo Direct 70 is becoming a
new normal for game releases on both
Xbox and Playstation with both companies
committing to it for their first party
titles but this would be a first for
Nintendo this might be confirmed to be
true by the time the direct drops later
today or it might be debunked let me
know in the comments which it was
whatever the case don't rush to buy
Nintendo's two-game tickets that they
sell for a hundred dollars wait to make
sure that tears of the Kingdom would be
a part of that deal but if it is and the
game is priced at 70 that would probably
be the best way to go what do you think
of February's additions to Game Pass
would you pace seventy dollars for tears
of the Kingdom let me know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
foreign
[Music]